hey I back with you I 100 last month
there was this story about the giraffe
skilled the you and
bitches lines actually run a patrons
you these shoulder because this huge
international outcry
they said there they had use in
population control various reasons
obvious not an expert
you handle reading everything that goes
on you I'm an expert
yeah that's really the bank I whether I
should be electro
I'll that was huge international right
and then just this
me that seems you kill or lines
a basically because the ring in a young
healthy like that
reroll I and that you will and they have
a much younger and would survive
they claim that they had try to send
the animals elsewhere and the workout I
hinges Louis that people that were easy
the people that were
SeaWorld which I did yards lavishly
tend to think that these people you
genuinely cared
and it is the city as you Gretsch words
people really
the yeah a real asset 'em when they do
things like this
this %um this is like the yea putting
down DOS which actually a state
is yet on what
which me it just right hard you'll see
there you lose you
America that would take me there or
anywhere this is a really
all topics you call on or not experts
steel but you gotta like look into sue
E ethical practices up so my
Louis is that do house animals they're
they're not there
is certainly and reading that sure that
they're no longer deterred
then %uh position exist you
I'm saying like trashy the only purpose
to take part conservation
seeing only a yeah you
they have the said related to the
conservation
the yet ok and the reason I say that is
because
look I understand its use are important
for educational purposes
well 30 animals out of their natural
habitat
putting them in the slot pages for
spectators
is house yes so he's in various the
giraffe which was
slow underclass you area I'm there are
was you know what this trap his loins
you ingredients Salt Lake its ESA
one there were numbers used up blouse
you know we have
yeah let's see it and
Suzlon no you know you guys are hard is
your
uses network pardo so we don't know
US House we have so as a result
since we don't know draft see we're
gonna go ahead hewlett
so easy thing about what happened with
the draft that they claim they're using
also for educational purposes because
the
the draft two lines they also the for
children which allow people are upset
about
in other people's this is sir I is
lying things up this is worries about
hard words the or that a
so I don't know how much you can say
about this but then I'll actually like
what
ish and it's like I d0 has she was
he and yet throughout lactation thinking
no the is this Johnny
mummies smart creature is doing tricks
all day
and imagine regalia here there are a lot
bigger than us
and put us in will change it it is do
tricks all day
you know he probably try to rule to so
so there's so many issues rate
the Internet experts i do. you just look
at what's going on
at me is disease that woodie
mines killing them just hit just here at
greater NY
yes not black white issue %uh
yen you always have to take a look at
the Ethics that's you
yet look at their resiliency leon is the
code you
not give me a good reason for why he did
that
the giraffe and also you very healthy
line up yeah so yeah well know what you
think because again we are not experts
in this topic
and that this is what it's all about
look back we're going to let go down
below
subscribe to this channel subscribers
and shower three do's
on each channel per week and
you innovative coffee
Reiki that more run didn't
the do
done